we're just gonna doing both at the same
time uh I think we're lovin ya
coronation Cora Nathan did you really
did you doesn't mean Owen there's no
with you know what he said Cora nation
you want to talk about the coronation
cuz like coronation because she's gonna
claw snagged take it away from general
Zelda and make it a Korra nation again
he literally just said this like this is
what happens before like we start
recording for reals but please upload
this into the final product only cuz you
start like the camera I can't think they
are brilliant way to work it in because
it was just such a brilliant joke that's
how his mind works it's the greatest
joke since cab bitches okay that was
it's phenomenal alright awful alright so
we're gonna do two this time
back-to-back because we are running a
little bit behind so what's this we
white man I've watched the other one
last Friday I tried to all right now
yeah that's right I I've been running a
little bit behind
um but who's ready to go that day that's
all days what um but yeah okay so we
have core alone which we'll talk about
personal talk about the Cora nation ah
God um so alright so uh
core alone we finally see what's been
happening with Cora how she got to this
day where she is uh and why she hasn't
gone back and told anybody where she was
going apparently her powers aren't as
good they used to be she's been spending
months and months wasn't like six months
learning how to walk something like that
trying to get her footing back literally
and she finally gets it back but she's
still a little rusty
and she's just feeling useless and she's
just not good she used to be hey I have
a hard time remembering cuz there's like
more than week ago it had like a Oh was
a week was like a week yeah head like Oh
Rambow sort of Deerhunter thing going
where she's like going to me fighting
yeah which is like going to these
fighting competitions and like hey
aren't you it's like there she's dead
it's just something like that like uh
and she keeps the well the big thing she
keeps being haunted by it just looks
like another her like her in the Avatar
State um you know just not looking good
and it keeps following her and her
what's that the spirit animal the little
doggie that side as well I wasn't yeah
the little dog which was a spirit animal
that's a side yeah it's like a little
poodle it's weird in my how am I the
only one who liked it first I'm just
like oh it's kind of like Wizard of
Earthsea you got your shadow self it's
all like you know psychological and like
you mian but like as I went on was I the
only wonder was Iggy hey you know this
kind of reminds me a Superman 3 when
he's fighting I forgive Legend of Zelda
2 thank you Oh shadow link legends of my
god that's old school you didn't really
go with the ocarina of time or no I'm
just as also comes back to Zelda because
again that just seems to be the magic
word we're throwing around here for
whatever reason um but yeah so she and
who does she come across at the very end
just when she thinks there's no hope and
nothing I can help her she caught us a
big shock right at need when that
wouldn't that a great switches yes Toth
wandered into the forest and has been
seen for years meditating it's like
Sokka it's just like oh well I'm sure
it's out there somewhere oh well yeah in
what was not a big surprise at all
everybody knew everybody knew was coming
apparently except for the few people on
my Facebook page you what I posted I
like the spoilers wrong about what we
live in
did you not see the trailer where she
says Toph or yeah so Thaksin this
apparently that was the synchrony
implicit no but that I've been living in
cave they can live in the cave with her
and stay with their sight and still not
know she would be in this season even
though the trailers I said it the last
season's like yeah she just wandered off
I'm just dropping that bit of
information no reason at all just you
know there you go audience do with it
what you will it's like come on guys
it's a really like I'm in Europe I
didn't see the term I'm like but you
have a computer all the last season I'm
like I get it if somehow a North Koreans
slip through Anna this is like spoilers
but like there's no excuse you can watch
it on your computer it's not like you
know last year we're Nickelodeon was
actually running it on their goddamn TV
station um so comes across her that's
the end of that episode um I guess we
could talk about that every of oh just
talking about the episode ah it is funny
if they didn't have the amount of time
going by like the the six months in the
three years and stuff like that I
probably would have seen it as
especially strong but because it you
have to squeeze all that in a half-hour
but I think because you're constantly
reminded yet for a long time she can't
walk uh uh and this is over months and
months and even when she can watch she
doesn't have her powers bag and she
doesn't know why and she's being haunted
by something this is going on for you
know as we hear three minutes of
spiritual journey it shows us something
we didn't see it shows us something we
were literally robbed of I think in
season two because of the way the whole
show got put together so haphazardly
which is like can you imagine season two
opened with that sort of episode like
imagine that you know she just kind of
gets her powers back but she's still
overcoming the idea of losing her powers
or a mom
fucked her up somehow or you know ladies
this is
this is literally I thought the apology
for everything that went down in the
beginning of season 2 yeah you're right
because this is her consequences yes
you're getting a bad thing I think it's
true God that is it is so weird it is
like they're really trying to
reconstruct uh what I'm sure a lot of
people instead of been mistakes um well
if you look at what was trying to go on
I think season 3 is almost a means to
kind of redo some concepts of season one
it's he wants to kill the avatar instead
of taking away her powers but it's a
similar concept just I don't think you
know I think we just have humans ruling
everything I think there shouldn't be in
avatar so Amon was doing about just
removing the power is kind of painlessly
but you know um in season 3 2 is more
I'm gonna cover but it's the same
concept and I'm like huh it's almost
like I don't know what if they realize
that they listen to the criticisms or
just felt in their hearts that yeah we
didn't get to do this quite right
because of the way like we kept conduct
around by management so they're like
let's do that same idea again really
flesh it out kind of do it right this
time it just has that vibe to it but the
same sort of an artistic quality to the
villains in season 3 and now picking up
in season 4 with chaos and suing and
listen edit it's almost like a redo of
season 1 well won't reboot but like
they're kind of like hitting the same
notes again what I like too is then the
last season was very much an arc II
these people are you know members of
they're just pure and are kiss uh
obviously the villain in this one is
very much about order and structure and
I like that and I like how also in the
last season you know the chorus pretty
strong and go in and out for Avatar
state and everything uh and in this one
she's very very weak trying to get her
powers back um so I sort of like that
like they start having these different
liens uh and I think about saying before
about the actual you know that the
amount of time passing makes a big
difference is that if this was like you
know whatever a month or two or
something like that she's like you know
I'm so frustrated
been doing stuff I might be by appeal
you know with it shut up what's wrong
with the all the world doesn't need me
all didn't boohoo what's you know okay
you're the Abba that was like past
episodes I need you Twinkletoes get up
ya bum well we'll get to that a second
too but yeah I think I like you know
over a short amount of time you sort of
say well it almost seems like a selfish
thing to get upset about just like all
the world doesn't need Mia stuff over
years and years and trying so hard to
get you know not just your power but
kind of your identity back as well yeah
you know you're pretty much told from
childhood I get both Aang and her head
bang comma that they were told as
children they are the avatar uh uh you
know well she just discovers it's a
spiritual journey
that's something the original show had
which has been kind of missing I haven't
like touched upon their yet fun here and
there but Ruby hardcore like we're gonna
examine a spiritual journey with her
herself like I I haven't seen a ton of
that this one least not handled really
great and this time they're just like no
we're really gonna do this she's faced
with a situation that completely drains
her destroys her spiritual and she's
gonna build herself back up you know and
that that's something Aang did you know
he had to face the fact of losing his
culture and this and that and basically
sort of get himself retrained and figure
out what he was gonna do and it's nice
to see that hmm so cuz that's where I
thought the original show was strongest
I think that's where this show can be
strongest too so uh I thought was a good
episode I thought it you know like I
said especially considered the amount of
time going by I thought it definitely
show what she was going through and it's
much after the first one that has so
much information just going from place
to place to place and just so much you
know weight being thrust upon you assert
nice to have just one person and see
what that person's going through and you
don't know anything about what's
happening in the rest of the nation rest
of the world kind of like how she
doesn't know either cuz I see Katara
again - yeah lies she's made in most of
the seasons I think yeah this is very
Katara heavy for
yeah sure yeah no that's very true um
and yeah so so I I really liked it uh
they get this one be Cora nation um I
would just sort of back to the kif this
is a fun Futurama
oh it's it kind of gets back with a kind
of a mix of the two this is the first
episode where you kind of see like a
half and half of here's the world shit
here's course shit going on it's a whole
bunch of shit whole bunch of shit and
you know she she's using the toughest
Yoda pretty much I don't know it's kind
of office such a bore Yoda video is it's
yoda crossed with like burgess Meredith
from rocky up back help you I can't yes
but you get out get up you bum how are
cheating lightning you are and crapping
thunder you will um yeah that's a good
comparison I like that oh I left a
little bit wife's our hair in the bun
again bet that made me laugh a bit I
that makes me laugh cuz I've just looked
is this cuz she's got a visitor for the
first time in forever because I'm like
pushing dressing up for she's blind
what is shit loophole thank her close
agree clean too I get there in Aswan
yeah she what she looked like crap when
you know in the previous episode and now
all sudden she's done up like her old
hair and then I don't know
oh so Cora's trying to train with her to
get her power back figure out what's
wrong with her tough baby leads just
enjoy being the shit out of her and
doesn't even hide it
she's such a delightful bitch I am ah
missed her so much and it's fine cuz I
was thinking myself well okay is the
same kind of an to she has as a little
kid is it gonna you know is she gonna
become annoying as an adulterer a a very
old a dolphin stuff it's like not even
funny
oh no an even funnier like I did read
somewhere somebody's like don't you
think your personality would change
she's still like an overgrown tender if
I'm like no it's called second childhood
no no she's old enough that she doesn't
Carol is right I think what she was um
you know they had a police and all that
sudden guys catching me off her then she
had to really close down be serious and
I see that part with her two daughters
she's like I cannot take this right now
just go leave me alone at me it's like
you can tell she had a lot of shit going
on and that was very serious but now
she's an old lady she's away from
everybody but she still kicked ass and
she's you know at the very physical and
stuff so she's like I just get me
whatever fuck out why hello and she says
oh I forgot how much fun it is just a
Torme at the an attire oh good time so
so that's going on they find out that
she still has some metal inside her from
the poison uh that they didn't entirely
get it out so she's like oh great that's
the solution we'll take it out take it
out and she big shock she can't relax
herself uh an order table she nut wants
to be sick hmm
what the twist um so maybe it's also an
extension of her shadow self which she's
been fighting for the past episode okay
it's pretty obvious okay um but yeah so
and talk again just in that great talk
that the only way Tom can do is just
like you know what was just like well
how am I supposed to get rid of the how
explicit I don't know figured out
yourself you cry-baby hit everything
yeah bomb you know this um soap it's
such a great character because so many
people in this world but both this and
Avatar uh were so much it like you say
it's about the spiritual journey it's
been explaining this show is also for
kids so it's good uh but yeah every once
well it's like I think everybody
sometimes just needs that little smack
on the back of the head saying you know
just top it up like happens Canterbury
you know every once in a while uh and I
think for her to constantly be that but
it's also kind of helpful and
informative uh it's still such a great
character um so so that's one part of
the story going on another part is the
Oh Nazis yes
Adolf Zelda is officially taking over no
she went from general Zelda and now
she's declared herself I believe God
Emperor Zelda yes yes it breaks
oh but yeah I suppose you hear Empire
it's like I I had the lamp goes like I
said that away with Empire looks like I
don't like like all that talk about
Empire and I was just kinda like it
sounds kind of Star Wars II I mean it
seems like a lot of people like her
already but you're just from a PR
standpoint is anyone ever heard of a
friendly Empire a peaceful Empire it's
just not a very um hey bring your family
to our Empire it just it doesn't usually
fly uh but doesn't matter people seem to
be on her side I mean the British Empire
was all cute and about drinking tea and
stuff and it worked great if you weren't
you know anywhere else in the world
that's it said hate mail to hear your
apps you're absolutely right it okay
there's no really good empire it it
doesn't happen so anyways it's just not
a friendly sounding word you know again
could conduct a fiower person but uh so
how about like Imperial community there
you community wonderful Ward and a
little community to get in as parks to
it's a forced community playground boy
it's like being forced to go on a slide
we I would love to be forced to go on us
like uh a highly encouraged Commonwealth
that like to see a much better turns
just just for future um so but yeah she
pretty much right in the middle of like
you know the other Emperor's but that
why she was there for like two seconds
uh or their King whatever of the earth
Kingdom is she just like after she likes
it angle across of me will be crushed I
just want to take the mic it just go pop
just drop it on the full of it and now
we award you the medal of freedom and
I'm like our most ironic of metal
here Kingdom well I got she crushes it
to I yeah I want to shout like Matthew
simple reason yeah but it here's my only
thing like I was one of those moments
where I'm just like did it not occur to
any of the leaders in the crowd many of
whom have bending powers you know she
doesn't seem to be surrounded by many
like of her own people there I mean you
know it's a coronation it seems like it
was meant for the world leaders can
they've just taken her out right there
and been like and you're under arrest
yeah I don't I look at question answered
that was my first thing I would have
said his king she's like you have no
authority I would be like and bullshit
you're under arrest for esta yeah
honestly I really thought like I thought
your guitar by her way out of it yeah
and outs are like I was waiting for it
I'm like what and and then you just let
her leave well yeah
what doesn't only one I thought that was
kinda watching it's like you know I
don't think this is how this works no
wonder they've always got anarchists and
terrorists attacks nobody doesn't he I
would so yeah I kind of agree and it's
like well and then it's like knock on
the door hey he can't do that it's like
I I don't think this is gonna work guys
um but it's the badass it was terrible
it was wrong and again I like she even
though she's clearly the villain she's
still very identifiable in her ways and
everyone when she explains herself you
kind of see like I mean yeah I get up
just do you have to do this yes I do no
you don't you know but you still get
where she's coming from this Hitler guy
really did fix the roads I gotta give
him this no no I suppose it's still
obviously wrong I I know what you're
saying it's been given her which is
again what a lot of thuggish types will
do you know you give people the
incentive to vote for them you know and
then that you basically take over so
it's like well I fed you people I help
you people out I brought order and peace
and prosperity to the guy
you know so just don't fight me when I
say I want to take off her is is
somebody wrote I think when their plate
to if they just roses of your kingdom
ends with thunderous okay this is how
the earth kingdom ends with a whiny
little earth King crying and everybody
else doing nothing well I see the other
thing I think is kind of just by as as
annoying as that new earth King is that
was kind of funny him taking this at
their way from the key Donna's birthday
it's my coronation oh my god I remember
when you did that at Chuck E Cheese well
they should given me my pizza on time
instead of being five seconds late they
were on the clock I think you know I
don't like I was the only kid who timed
my okay I'm sorry good I don't like the
earth king as a carrot well you really
ran with that chucky cheese joke yes
there was a throw away from me in sis's
but I don't like the earth king as a
character but I do I'm here to hear it
and on hold on let's see I think if I go
to no turn the volume up yeah so I don't
like the earth king as a character um
but I do kind of like the comedy they go
for with him at the same time I think
that scene at the earth Kingdom buffet
in lured in their version of like the
earth Kingdom Chinatown was like finally
my tipping point where I'm just like
okay this character somebody needs to
kill her this is like I just I was just
done I have when I'm like this is too
pathetic even for a pathetic character I
get I just can't do this I think if
there was um I think there's a part way
of saying like you know yeah after he'll
be in for you know
Amaka you can leave a know what smoke
we're gonna do that we're both kinda
like oh good good my god right
seems to still be around so it's like
and he's so pathetic I don't know if
there's gonna be like oh he'll become
smart and find redemption like it seems
like he's so rock about him I'm not sure
if they can even pull that off now Oh
cuz I don't know if I would be able to
suspend my disbelief the one I did love
this email where he's upset at the
stalls selling uh the signs just for
that line just hey you spilled juice on
me good
I do Kali Weezer's respect the brush I
was kind of funny if I yeah it's like
that not too much else oh oh the best
one though still goes to Bolin when Mach
is like wow you look all important and
authoritative now and bones like yeah
when I stare at the mirror in the
morning sometimes I think I'm in trouble
and I'm just like oh no it's just me
they're right in this a lot of good
laughs in this way it's great seeing the
twins back again Oh more rare you always
pray more fair again looks like he's
working on some sort of evil was not my
girlfriend she's my boss boss girlfriend
same difference um but yeah I think um
I'm trying to think what wor something I
bet the only thing I think I had a
little trouble buying in it was that I
don't know if I could see uh Bolin quite
I'm he is like he kind of stood up he's
like okay but just and I like setting
the the brothers against each other and
him making the argument but I can't see
him quite going that director I couldn't
see him standing up applauding MVP was
doing kind of hesitant you know is
almost lost and and I could just cuz the
look on his face said it all it was just
I mean they do obviously show that he's
not necessarily happy with if he feels
it has to be done oh I don't know I
think it's that scene with her just
saying you know my house now and I don't
know I can see him just being like you
know sort of sitting there like not
standing just sort of thinking it over
you know like he doesn't know what to do
I think he wants to believe the best
well I mean he did basically just tell
her straight up he's like I don't feel
like all the crushing freedom - huh yeah
I like that I like that they had come
yeah and I I mean let's just be honest
Baldwin's just an idiot so but he's
still kind of like he's naive and when
honorable IDEO is an honorable idiot but
I think that's what it is I think he's
an honorable way they like I think he
wants to see the best in this person and
he'll come to realize eventually unless
we had talked about this like just as a
joke but it was like what if the
ultimate twist is kuvera is the good guy
yeah like she's actually not available
obviously she's very obviously the bag
up I'm like man that would have been a
twist that she's a dictator but a
benevolent tuchus is not gonna happen
that the of the other no idea really
strange twist tomorrow I was gonna say
the other scene I thought was a really
good point again just to show like how
people could side with her cuz other
times it's like again in Star Wars you
have like the Emperor like with the hood
and the evil smile and I join my
friendly Empire and I and she trusts me
but I like that you know when when bolus
is amok oh he says you know do you
really think that guy in there that
everything deserves to rule more than
she does and he's like fright ups as
well yeah well but no but it's the way
it is I have to respect the rules and
stuff so I do like it's like they do
address that that there is this element
of no it's not fair and there are people
are just gonna be like if it's not fair
why do it you know there's no wiggle
room at all it's just not fair don't do
it she should be in charge under be in
charge and then she'll do things best
right or do everything and everything
over uh so again I kind of like that
there's if it was like a good king is
very you know like all this guy's goofy
a good ruler but then this evil person
comes say because that's usually how it
works in a lot of takeover stories it's
like the ruler before not for realistic
take take arms right just you know shows
and movies and stuff it's like it's
always a good king or queen and then the
evil villain comes along somehow gets
voted in no they guys are something yeah
no I like the fact that again you see
where the sympathizers are coming from
and I think that makes the idea of
taking her down even tougher and even
more realistic you know because they are
going to be sympathizers and you can see
why so uh alright don't be stupid be a
smarty come and join the not-see party
yes I think you're fighting for kuvera I
don't know I'm definitely not fighting
for kuvira I'm saying yeah you can see
uh everything is still laid out in terms
of why she's doing what she's doing and
why she thinks she should be it and why
other people think she should be it also
as opposed to oh this is just an evil
person it would just come out and admit
it you're a closet fascist aren't you
closet I'm so be having strong um it's
more of a religious extremist sort of
thing but what's a fellow fascist do a
Newton I just coming out that's just to
shoot people should be okay shootings
barrel Owen mobs you gotta have moms and
mobs people shooting and mobs Friday
be there what the god one cycle this
shows up to my place just like with the
torch of the gun line I got a sandwich
Friday pitch for um so no I just like it
but honestly I mean you were talking
about Hitler and everything and you were
showing me a while ago the well the
world wars uh oh yeah thank you men tree
that was a man History Channel and it
shows I mean so many people do like to
just say Hitler was a monster
no evil he's the embodiment of evil
nothing else's stuff they had to get
there somehow and they had to become
this on how and how did they do that and
there had to be again sort of this
intention whether if is he stepping
stones from down I had a rotten life -
now I'm jilted - now I'm just becoming
crazy - now I'm a murderous man you know
and there's something about like when
people's just and not just evil
that's it and it's like it's not that
simple and I think it's good to
understand that it's good to address
that that's why I like that they are
what's the same with the public -
there's always a stepping stone of why
don't know if I would do that well okay
just this once okay I'll vote for this
guy even though I don't agree with some
of his policies and the next thing you
know you've got a crazy in power and
it's like of happened Ivan's away - good
yeah or maybe you're crazy or so he's
like now this guy's my kind of guy mob
beatings for all so uh but ya know again
I like this is the first episode where
certain mixes the to the stuff with core
and the stuff with the rest of the world
it's only way I can put it and and I
think they bounce out well and they mix
well and I served my fear was that well
Mike I know like all the world stuff but
not the core stuff and are they gonna
meet OK in the middle and they seem to
core one's really strong this time yeah
I can't point to them and be like oh
weak link well especially not we have
talked in there to think of there's a
weakling the only weak link is and it's
not Mako's fault this is Marco getting
specialty earth care ouch Alice gotta
say even it's like it's not it's not
Marcos well it's like the writers again
we're gonna stick up with this wholly
unlike
all character well must be house motto
has never been that interesting a
character either I mean we talking about
this guy where he's not like a horrible
carries just you could make it
interesting but I think once again
they've paired him now with this clown
and it is like oh poor market so very
end you're not gonna have an interesting
story yeah so it's always like our just
yeah anytime cuts back toe it is sort of
like just oh please just just be funny
this time baby shit I just realized
something what happened to Asami
we didn't see her this I you know I was
counting on that to she she didn't feel
this dinner I need more Asami
make it so I realize it's already
written but yeah I'm using my mind to
travel back in time I don't think it
worked right bad your fuckin bag bag
you're the Nazi yeah well see you next
time from the Nazi on the madman hi this
is Rob saying I think you got that